Hey look guys my name is Anna welcome
back to my Gammage in the series so last
time we talked about resizing how to
handle our application our window
properly resizing check out that video
if you haven't already and today I'm
going to be having a nice little
maintenance episode cool
I love maintenance episodes to be honest
because I think that maintaining code is
something that is extremely difficult I
think that to kind of keep programming
and would like without accumulating tech
debt is really a challenge and I think
that everyone even senior engineers
struggle with this at times it's
something that you kind of pick up like
strategies to mitigate that you kind of
pick up throughout your career and you
keep building on it and everyone has
their little things that they do to kind
of make sure that you're not just
programming programming programming
programming because your mind wants to
get that sub down you want to get stuff
to work you want to actually get a
running program down you want to just
put all that code that's in your brain
out onto the keyboard and compile it and
you want it to run you want to build
these massive projects that just worked
when I just jam it in but there comes a
time where you have to just stop you
have to just think mmm that's stuff that
I did really quickly because I couldn't
be bothered doing it properly that stuff
that I just wanted to jam in so that my
application would run today because I
want to see results on the screen today
that me I need to go back to that I need
to fix that up because now my future
ideas are gonna suffer as a result of me
kind of making some not poor decisions
but just the first iteration of
something that I wanted to just get down
into my code as quickly as possible so
that I could have something cool to show
everyone has this right not just
personal projects not just people
working on personal projects you can
look at game studio Springs for example
right we have crunch time well I
wouldn't obviously the game in the games
industry as a whole tries to reduce
crunch time but still we have that time
before release where we have a deadline
we have to wrap up this massive project
but the thing is this project is huge
this project you know you go on like a
JIRA and you see that there's a little
over a thousand open issues the QA has
just been like mmm it crashes when you
do this or this isn't supposed to happen
but it does so many different bugs so
what do you do you go through as many of
them as you can they use patch them up
and here I'm worried about well
technically speaking I should spend
three days working on a proper fix nor
because you have a deadline you have to
finish that stuff up so this happens to
two large companies this happens to
small companies this happens to
individuals this happens to people still
in uni learning programming this is
something that affects everyone and
whilst we don't really like we don't
have that much tech debt per se because
these this has not been some kind of
marathon like 48-hour programming
challenge in which I've written hazel
and from scratch in 48 hours which
obviously I could definitely do but it
probably wouldn't be this good this is
like a kind of step by step series on
how to build a game engine quote-unquote
properly obviously everything in shared
in this series is completely my opinion
everyone's gonna have different opinions
think that the more senior someone is
like the more experienced someone is
they're probably gonna have like a
wildly different opinion and I'm gonna
stick to their opinion and think it's
hard to come across people who are
humble enough to admit that well you
know I respect the way that you've done
things even though it's different to me
but ultimately you know we've written
this in somewhat of a way of a way that
I've tried to mitigate take that as much
as possible but still down the road you
know especially me developing my hazel
development branch which is a much more
mature and fully featured kind of well
not fully featured but more featured
version of hazel that as a result of me
developing that I've realized obviously
there's some things work I've done some
things differently there and that's
totally like that's totally normal
because I mean ultimately speaking if
you were to sit down and if you were to
rewrite your software project three
times you're not gonna you're not gonna
write it the same way three times you're
gonna write the whole thing out first
finished right you sit down the second
time you've got how many things
differently might be because you just
you feel like it you just like I don't
want to do the same thing again that's
boring right might be because along the
way of you designing it the first time
you figured out that actually this is a
problem or it just might be because you
just realized that I could just do this
so much better right I mean it doesn't
well the first time but I this is more
efficient way of doing this that I
realized because I now have a grasp of
the whole problem of the whole problem
stuff that you kind of just get
the time right and so I don't want to
like I don't want to talk too much about
this now I think that it's definitely
important to consider these things but
because of the fact that I've written it
kind of multiple times in a way I've
been like well I've done things
differently in hazel dev just because I
could really just because I was like
well you know we don't need to do this
there's some stuff in hazel that's not
in hazel dev and there's obviously a lot
more in hazel Devon on hazel but
ultimately because it's a more more
complete project and that's why I wanted
to make hazel dev I can look back and
actually take things from hazel dev and
be like well you know someone's like
looking into the future a little bit and
being like well we're gonna have to
handle things this way for it to work
properly so let's take some of those
back now and check them out hazel dev by
the way is available to all the patrons
that do so help support this series pass
on a couple accession to the Cherno have
you guys pledged at a certain tier
you'll get access to all of the source
code behind hazel dev which is like a
fully featured kind of PBR renderer you
know we've got like animation going on
there we've got best for like a viewer
where you can load custom textures
custom models stuff like that definitely
check it out and help support the series
thank you to all the wonderful patrons
who do help support the series because
you guys are the ones that make this
possible it's why I'm sitting here right
now talking to a camera stead of doing
something different anyway let's get
back into this I want to just take a
look at a few things
um well specifically I might just
describe what we're doing today first I
think we're gonna just take a look at
hazel we're just gonna take a look at a
bunch of code I'm I I do have some notes
but I'm gonna kind of go off the book
here and see what I can do because I
just want to take a look at hazel and I
want to see what changes need to be made
because there are some things that I
want to do like that I want to just
upgrade for example we've been using
Visual Studio 2017 2019 has been out for
a while like the official release has
been out for a while and on hit you know
hazel dev is using 2019 so I just want
to basically move hazel from Visual
Studio 2017 to 2019 that's like step one
the other thing is to do with organizing
files essentially we've got a lot of
files and folders that I've basically
sorted that out completely differently
in hazel dev so I just want to take a
look at that maybe you will clean up the
actual repository a little bit more
we'll do kind of just maintenance tasks
that don't really change the way that
hazel runs what I'm building any new
features here but what we are doing is
maintained
what we've already got we're refining
what we've already got we're organizing
it in a little bit of a better manner
and the reason I'm doing this now is
because of course we're a bad start this
whole 2d renderer thing which will
probably do next week if not the week
after and ultimately it's always good to
approach a next kind of large step by
just refining what you've already got
making it so that everything's honestly
organized because you don't want to
start working on a big feature if the
code is kind of a mess not that it is a
mess but you know you still want to want
to get the code to it to as good a place
as possible before you start with
something else let's dive in and take a
look at what we need to do to make this
stuff happen so this is the hazel
repository as it appears right now there
are a few things that I would change
well the first one really is to do with
pre make so if we take a look at our
generate project script file just open
it here in North pad currently it
generates Visual Studio 2017 now I would
like to change this to 2019 now to do
that we're gonna need a slightly
different version of pre make that we
started off with I think that through a
series of pull requests we have actually
or just like me maybe at one point I
think I did just upgrade pre-make to to
the latest version of przemek which
supports Visual Studio 2019 so it
actually I think will work with the exe
that is in the repository as it stands
we'll check it out in a minute though if
not you'll have to go to the pre-make
repository and if you click on releases
so if you kind of just add that the base
repository which is github.com such
pre-make slash pre-med course what this
is if you click on releases here where
it says 19 releases you'll see this kind
of pre-med 5.0 alpha 14 and this is just
the latest version happens to be from
the 6th of May it does support village 3
or 2019 I'm not sure why they added
support for 2019
it was definitely at some point at some
point recently but anyway if you just
basically go down to the bottom of this
on
assets and you download the pre-make 5.0
alpha 14 windows - zip file that will
contain the exe file and of course if
you're running this on Mac or Linux even
though we don't officially support that
it should be too much work to make that
stuff work because everything we've
written so far has been cross-platform
you might need to set up like gel fw to
compile for mac or linux and stuff like
that and in fact I will stay tuned
because if you're interested in other
platforms very very soon we're gonna
start supporting both Mac and Linux
that's literally like I mean did this
year for sure so I'm definitely gonna
add support for that officially through
premake and it just picks up everything
else that we do get everything building
and I do actually want to add continuous
integration to this engine as well so
that every commit is like compiled and
validated on Windows Mac and Linux so we
haven't officially support those
platforms suppose you interested none of
the code we've actually written has been
Windows specific at all I've made sure
we do have like Windows window for
example does it appear with all that
stuff that looks like it's my way into
Windows only but it just uses gel of W
there's nothing really that I've written
does like specifically win32 API only so
because of that you should be able to
take all the curd from hazel yourself
right now and compile it on Mac or Linux
the only problems I can see and it might
be wrong because I'm tried but the only
problems that I can see the fact that my
pre make file that I wrote for GL of W I
believe that's only that that only
supposed windows because I've only
compiled the windows files there but if
you just instead of compiling the
windows files if you can pilot for Mac
or Linux by just including those files
instead I'll taking a look at you know
you could also join download just a jail
talking binary essentially for that I'm
you should be okay so that's kind of
that's kind of well we're out right now
with platforms but don't worry that will
be coming very soon so that's kind of
the idea download that if you haven't
already and then you'll have to unzip it
and put it into we saw that invent of
being pre make and then the pre make 5
WX C file so if we're gonna go back here
to hazel and if we run generate projects
now that we've changed it to be bs 2019
let's see if that actually works ok so
it does say error no such action vs 2019
so
means that we don't actually have the
right version of frame EXO I actually
felt that we did but we didn't so it's
hard to keep track I think between what
we actually haven't not because of that
hazel Deb branch so what I'll do is I'll
download basically everything that is
said I'm gonna do now because we don't
have that so I've downloaded it I've
copied that premake 5ghz file then dab
in premium
paste it in here replace the file and
that is it as as simple as it is just
generate projects again and you can see
that this time it's actually gonna build
everything now I really don't like this
if error level like paws thing because
you can see that I wanted to actually
see the output there but it disappeared
because it was successful I don't like
that I always want to see the output of
this so what I want to do is actually
just get rid of that that was accepted
during a pull request but I'm going back
on that because I just want to I won't
actually see everything sorry I forgot
that I forgot to pause so let's get
generate projects again and you can see
that this timing works sir
and specifically I wanted to see - 2017
should also work if I run generate
projects with 2017 you can see
everything here gets created
successfully and then of course if we go
back to 2019 we should be able to
generate whatever you're using so hazel
as as it stands right now today I'm
gonna have that support 2019 so
basically you should be downloading
Visual Studio 2019 to develop with hazel
if you really if you don't have 2019
right now or you want to test it with
2017 or whatever then you'll have to
edit this file and change it to 2017 or
2015 or whatever it is that you're using
over here so officially hazel from this
point forward requires Visual Studio
2019
okay cool so speaking of which this is a
bad file
it's a batch file right it's something
that is clearly Windows only so I don't
like that because I've just started
talking about different platforms and
how hazel is totally cross-platform but
this batch file clearly is known as a
Windows batch file so what I want to do
is a few things first of all I want to
rename it I want to call this like win
you know maybe build well I don't want
to call it build because that implies
compiling so just win and then maybe
generate or Jen projects okay
win Jen projects that
it and I don't want to leave it here I
want to I'm gonna make a scripts folder
for all of the different scripts we'll
have and we'll pop this here okay and we
can expand this in the future when we
have like you know Mac OS or Linux or
whatever we can have like the you know
like a Linux or POSIX you know gen
projects in there Mac Mac OS you know
gen projects whatever it is that we do
for different platforms we can have have
it there obviously they'll be like SH
files and not batch files but you kind
of get the point that way we kind of we
can see what scripts are meant for
Windows and then in the future when we
have a lot we could even separate this
into like separate folders but I'm not
gonna do that now because we literally
have one batch file and if we have three
for example that's not gonna be an issue
either I think that in the future it's
gonna be important to also you know to
look like CI purposes 15 years
integration purposes we might want to
have like a build project so build you
know solution or something like that
which is a which will basically maybe it
will generate projects as well not sure
if that's required but basically built
solution will just literally just call
Emma's build and build that solution so
you don't even have to open visual
studio to build everything and to get an
exe file out of that so that's kind of
what I'm gonna do with scripts in the
future but for now that that's that now
this isn't gonna work so we moved it so
make sure that you basically go back and
you change this to be to go back a
directory and called przemek otherwise
that's not gonna work so if I try this
the other thing is we're actually going
to get no pre-made script file found of
course because we need to be in a
different directory I should just do
this by doing push B so push directory
then we'll basically push the back
directory and then we'll pop it at the
end so what this will do is basically
your do a CD like a change directory to
that previous thing but it will remember
the directory apparently and so that you
can then when you pop it it'll actually
go back to the directory apparently and
so at this point we're actually in the
scripts directory well back in the
scripts directory to here in case we
want to run other scripts or do anything
like that so we have a push T pop d and
then we call fender bin pre-make blah
blah so now if I double click on this
you can see we should have everything
I mean yeah and we do and I will
actually turn that off so that we get a
little bit of some cleaner output as you
can see here okay cool
beautiful done I like that a lot that
script has been fixed a little bit and
refined looking good so let's think
about what else we need so you know
stuff like Premack files we could move
into like a build folder I'm not gonna
bother with that I remind having it in
the root directory let's go ahead and
open this because now it's Visual Studio
2019 does that even work let's take a
look okay so it's opening with 2017
that's fantastic I need to definitely
fix what I opened my solution files in
so we can basically open this with the
microsoft visual studio version selector
at furtherly wanter that way it will
select based on it'll read the file I
think a little bit and then select the
appropriate version of Visual Studio so
now we're using 2019 which is pretty
cool
I just installed it on this computer
like just then so I like Dorn or exactly
at what state this is in Mike yeah you
see my solution Explorer is on the wrong
side and all that kind of stuff so but
it doesn't really matter okay cool so
the first thing I want to do so we're in
debug x64 is just build the whole
solution you want to make sure that
everything runs and actually compiles if
for Visual Studio 2019 I think that a
lot of people see upgrading a visual
studio version as not a big deal like
other humans that I'll just get the new
one for small projects that probably is
the case but in real life in reality it
can be a pain to upgraded version of
Visual Studio especially if you're
working on a huge project the reason is
that you're not just upgrading Visual
Studio the IDE you're upgrading the
whole compiler and compilers have bars
believe it or not like it's very common
in a huge codebase where you've got a
lot of code a lot of legacy code a lot
of like maybe templates on macros or
things like that for your program for
your projects for your solution to just
not compile with a new version of Visual
Studio like you'll just say they're like
you know antennal compiler error or
whatever and you know just the compile
will crash like that happens especially
with new releases so that's why it's
important to like first test everything
relax this is hazel this is tiny right
now this purpose were not worried about
this at all but in the future if you're
working on more serious projects that
just keep that in mind that upgrading
your visual studio version is not
actually as trivial as it might seem
anyway as expected this did succeed
successfully while succeed successfully
is a great a great little phrase there
by me but everything did compiled
successfully and you can see that we can
launch this we can remove everything
around and it looks pretty good so that
is that let's quickly talk about the
folder structure of things because
that's the other thing that I wanted to
change so if we take a look at hazel
what we have here in sources we have
hazel and then we have a whole bunch of
stuff here in the root hazel directory
and we have like time step and call not
something I want not something I
intended to have it's just a lot of
stuff was made within here right so
application core entry point input key
codes layers you know log mouse button
codes orthographic camera control or
maybe not but like everything here
everything apart from orthographic
camera controller is cool right that
stuff is just the stuff that we have in
core orthographic camera controller we
can put in renderer perhaps mmm I like I
mean it's not the the best thing maybe
to put it into renderer just because
like ultimately speaking it's a
controller it's not to do with rendering
it's to do with like the application
kind of layers and stuff like that so
I'll put it here just because there's no
place there's another place for it I
don't think it fits into anything else
here whatsoever I don't want to put into
core either but ultimately that's like
the one that I'm questioning
orthographic camera controller whatever
camera should definitely be in renderer
but maybe not the controller so going
back to core yeah like that looks pretty
good to me I you know I'm not a big fan
of making folders like a lot of folders
I'm not a big fan of making a lot of
files either see that group stuff in
buffer for example so I don't want to
make core you know application layers
whatever no we're just gonna have call
and just a bunch of files here unless
this gets to like a hundred files and it
just looks like completely messy and
unmanageable I'm not gonna change that
because that's just kind of my opinion
cool okay now that we've done this we
should rerun the pre make script file
and then we'll
have to fix all of our included parts so
let's rerun that go back to visual
studio reload all and then we'll just
basically try and compile and we'll all
the errors that we get we will just go
through and fix all right so looking at
the output
well the PCH failed so I don't think
it's going to continue but hazel log is
now our hazel core log of course and
I'll just zoom in a little bit because
this there's no visuals to you change a
few things
well it just forgot my preferences and
then hazel application for example so
this stuff all becomes part of four
times that was already in there and this
stuff becomes part of coy except for the
orthographic camera control there which
is in the renderer let's see what else
entry point is now in core as well okay
let's build everything again this is
just kind of like a rinse and repeat
process but it's gonna kind of build it
every time I will just will let the
compiler find the errors for us instead
of just manually looking through every
file but I do expect we will probably
have a lot because whenever you move
folders like this that tends to be the
case so core layer layer stack can't
find something either so for my roommate
rename this to something like base in
the future will see just because it's
called base you know in the hazel
developing branch but just because and
this is a little bit slow here just
because you know in cordon H cross that
correlation doesn't sound great and also
it's kind of just a base header file
that we want to include almost
everywhere okay cool yeah see as you can
see core is included in a lot of places
it contains like macros that we use like
all the time I don't think we need this
everywhere back when we had hazel API it
was used everywhere but I don't think
that we necessarily need to have it
everywhere now like we did before anyway
so this is core input now this is core
window I'm not putting window in
renderer because it's not part of the
renderer technically you should be able
to render to any
think not necessarily winter so that's
why I'm not putting it there
let's try build again that looks pretty
good to me I think we fixed most of them
okay we got a few more in in in input so
cool layer stack oops
in the middle of compiling that I guess
still compiling that okay cool back to
output application H we'll just fix all
of these errors here both of these hazel
core layer stack that's correct right
I'm not sure why planning about that
hazel core LAN stack that should be okay
okay so to save you guys from watching
me fix all these errors slowly I've just
gone ahead and fixed all of them you can
see everything compiles successfully now
let's go ahead and run it again with
these changes and of course we should
get hazel opening as normal the other
thing that's really important to test is
all of your configurations so we have
release we don't really support this
right now I'm not even sure if it will
compile it's yeah I mean we're not
distributing hazel just yeah we're not
just distributing any applications made
with hazel just yet so I'm not gonna
worry about that but release is
definitely important we'll make sure
that that compiles we've only got one
platform so we don't need to do that but
just it really important when you do
change things like this do not just
compile debug can't tell you how many
times people have committed code like a
work in the past for example and they've
only tried compiling it in debug then
I'll release it doesn't compile at least
or doesn't work properly noise so make
sure that you test all of your
configurations before you commit do I do
this nor you know especially on like a
project like hazel long stuff ah you
know it's easy to fix it's fine but if
you are actually working on a project
that's important and you know it's a
kind of you want it to actually be like
as how you want your card to be as high
quality as possible make sure that you
just take a take a step back and just
test it in debug and release or whatever
other configurations you have so you
don't have to check it in and then just
have this you know this the continuous
integration just be like your commit did
not build because that's that's just
embarrassing no one wants that alright
so this is a success
of course and I'll just run it and
release as well and as you can see there
we have release running correctly okay
so that's gonna wrap up this episode
just a few mention of things that I want
to get out of the way of course as many
many more there's a lot of pull requests
that I need to actually look at there's
a lot of other things that I'm sure I
would clean up and change such as
looking through all of the compiler
warnings that's gonna be your guys job
I've given you the task what I want you
guys to do is actually go ahead and pull
the latest version of hazel pull this
all the stuff that I've done which I
will commit and then take a look at all
of the warnings that you actually get as
a result of compiling hazel and see if
you can fix all of them that's gonna be
a task there's a few tricky ones in
there Muslims should be pretty
straightforward and then when you've
fixed all the warnings go ahead and open
a pull request in the hazel repository
and I will accept it and then we'll have
hazel warning free hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please hit the
like button also check out patreon for
such the show now if you want to support
this series and I will see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]